When Crypto’s golden boy lost his entire
empire overnight, instead of running away
from the spotlight, he ran towards it.
Appearing in interview after interview.
I’m deeply sorry about what happened.
I’ve had a bad month.
That is an understatement.
He showed signs of nervousness in this New
York Times interview.
Perhaps the gravity of a scandal that could
be bigger than Enron hit him.
Many wondered why in the world he wasn’t
arrested right away after losing billions
of dollars of customer funds when his cryptocurrency
exchange FTX collapsed in November.
It wasn’t until exactly one month, and one
day after FTX filed for bankruptcy, that police
in the Bahamas arrested SBF in his luxury
home he shared with roommates…at the request
of the U.S.
Hours before, SBF had been playing a video
game.
(Storybook brawl)
The Securities and Exchange Commission has
charged him with defrauding big investors
who committed nearly $2 billion in recent
years.
SEC’s chairman Gary Gensler said in a statement:
“We allege that Sam Bankman-Fried built
a house of cards on a foundation of deception
while telling investors that it was one of
the safest buildings in crypto.”
Sam Bankman-Fried reportedly used billions
in customer funds from FTX to prop up his
other company, Alameda Research, a hedge fund
that was in trouble after trying to bail out
other struggling crypto firms.
He reportedly built a “back door” in FTX’s
accounting software that let him move billions
of dollars from FTX to Alameda without flagging
the transactions to external auditors.
SBF has repeatedly denied that he did anything
wrong.
Did you know these funds were being funneled
to Alameda, what is your answer?
I did not know there was any improper use
of customer funds.
When the crypto website CoinDesk revealed
the close ties between SBF’s two companies,
FTX and Alameda, that made Binance nervous.
Binance is the world’s largest cryptocurrency
exchange that was an early investor in FTX.
And subsequently sold its stake in FTX, consisting
mainly of the FTX token FTT.
($580 million)
That caused the price of the token to plummet
and resulted in a domino effect of nervous
customers pulling out…leading to the spectacular
fall of FTX, which I covered in more detail
in another video.
Along the way, billions of dollars of customers’
funds also went missing.
Bankman-Fried has said that if he'd spent
'an hour a day' thinking about risk management
FTX might not have collapsed.
His companies thrived on risk.
Risk was baked into his company Alameda, whose
CEO was his ex-girlfriend Caroline Ellison,
a 28-year-old Harry Potter-loving math whiz.
This is how she described her business mentality.
I think being comfortable with risk is very
important.
We tend not to have things like stop losses.
I think those aren’t necessarily a great
risk management tool.
A stop-loss is designed to limit the maximum
loss of a trade by automatically selling an
asset once it reaches a certain value.
Not having a stop loss is INCREDIBLY risky.
Yet no one saw the signs of doom.
SBF and his team had everyone fooled.
He was called the next Warren Buffett.
It certainly didn’t help that superstars
like Tom Brady and Stephen Curry vouched for
FTX.
With FTX I have everything I need to buy,
sell, and trade crypto safely.
The glitz and glamour hid what some FTX users
call a Ponzi scheme….in which the first
investors are rewarded with money that’s
actually been invested by later investors,
rather than making money from a legitimate
product or service.
The mastermind of a massive Ponzi scheme,
Bernie Madoff, ripped off tens of thousands
of people of as much as $65 billion.
Madoff was sentenced to 150 years in prison.
Could SBF suffer the same fate?
He is set to be extradited to the U.S., where
federal prosecutors are charging him with
wire fraud, wire fraud conspiracy, securities
fraud, securities fraud conspiracy, money
laundering.
AND, violating campaign finance laws.
He was the darling of the Democrats, donating
millions to them…though he now says he secretly
gave roughly the same amount to Republicans.
If convicted, he faces a maximum sentence
of 115 years.
The fall of one of the largest cryptocurrency
exchanges is another nail in the coffin of
an already fragile crypto market that has
yet to recover from the crash in the spring.
Can people trust crypto ever again?
Is Binance safe?
The U.S. Department of Justice has been investigating
Binance since 2018, including its founder
Changpeng Zhao.
Reuters reported that it has to do with Binance's
compliance with U.S. anti-money laundering
laws and sanctions.
In order to make an informed decision about
whether to invest in crypto, it’s important
to understand how it works.
Brilliant is a great way to learn the math
and the technology behind cryptocurrencies
through hands-on puzzles.
On Brilliant’s website or app, you can learn
the mechanics of maintaining and securing
a cryptocurrency, and then, you can decide
for yourself if crypto is a fad.
My viewers also love Brilliant's Computer
Science Fundamentals course, where you can
learn the fundamentals of computer science
- and no coding is required.
Brilliant is great if you’re studying or
if you’re already working and want to brush
up on your math, science, and computer science
skills.
I personally use Brilliant to improve my critical
thinking skills by going through their Logic
courses.
Brilliant is FREE to try out if you head to
the custom link in my description: brilliant.org/newsthink.
And the first 200 people who use my custom
link will get 20% off Brilliant’s annual
Premium subscription, which gives you access
to all of their course offerings.
Thanks for watching.
For Newsthink, I’m Cindy Pom.